a small tangent on that
it is a fascinating open question to me
on the topic of driving
whether you know supervised learning
people
machine learning people think you have
to like drive to learn how to drive
to me it's very possible that just by us
humans
by first of all walking but also by
watching
other people dr not even being inside
cars as a passenger
but let's say being inside the car as a
passenger but even just
like being a pedestrian and crossing the
road you learn
so much about driving from that it's
very possible
that you can without ever being inside
of a car
be okay at driving once you get in it
or like watching a movie for example i
don't know something like that
it's have you have you taught anyone to
drive
no so except myself i have two children
and um i learned a lot about car driving
because my wife doesn't want to be the
one in the car while they're learning so
that's my job yeah so i sit in the
passenger seat
and it's really scary um you know i have
wishes
to live um and they're you know they're
figuring things out now
they start off very
[Music]
very much better than i imagine uh like
a neural network would right
they get that they're seeing the world
they get that there's a road that
they're trying to be on
they get that there's a relationship
between the angle the steering but it
takes a while to not be very jerky
and so that happens pretty quickly like
the ability to stay in lane
at speed that happens relatively fast
it's not zero shot learning but
it's pretty fast the thing that's
remarkably hard and this is i think
partly why self-driving cars are really
hard
is the degree to which driving is a
social interaction activity yes
and that blew me away i was completely
unaware of it until i watched my son
learning to drive
and i was realizing that he was sending
signals to all the cars around him
and those in his case he's he's always
had
social communication challenges
he was sending very mixed confusing
signals to the other cars and that was
causing the other cars to drive
weirdly and erratically and there was no
question in my mind
that he would he would have an accident
because
they didn't know how to read him there's
things you do with the the speed that
you drive the positioning of your car
that you're constantly like in the head
of the other drivers
and seeing him not knowing how to do
that and having to be taught explicitly
okay you have to be thinking about what
the other driver is thinking
was a revelation to me yeah i was
supposed to be really not so so creating
kind of uh theories of mind of the other
theories of mind of the other cars
yeah yeah which i just hadn't heard
discussed in the self-driving car
talks that i've been to since then
there's some people who do do
consider those kinds of issues but it's
way more subtle than i think
there's a little bit of work involved
with that when you realize
like when you especially focus not on
other cars but on pedestrians for
example
it's a literally staring you in the face
yeah yeah yeah so that when you're just
like how do i interact with pedestrians
um you have like pedestrians you're
practically talking to an octopus at
that point they've got all these weird
degrees of freedom you don't know what
they're going to do they could turn
around any second
but the point is we humans know what
they're going to do
like we have a good theory of mind we
have a good mental model of
what they're doing and we have a good
model of
the model they have a view and the model
of the model of the model like
they're we're able to kind of reason
about this kind of uh
the social like game of it uh all
the hope is that it's quite simple
actually that it could be learned that's
what i just talked to the waymo i don't
know if you know
that company it's google south africa
they
i talked to their cto about this podcast
and
they like i wrote in their car and it's
quite aggressive and it's quite
fast and it's good and it feels great it
make it also just like tesla
waymo made me change my mind about like
maybe driving is
easier than i thought maybe i'm just
being
speciesist
maybe uh it's a speciesist argument yes
i don't know
but it it's fascinating to think about
like the same
as with reading which i think you just
said you avoided the question but i
still hope you answered it somewhere
they avoided it brilliantly it is
there's blind spots there's artificial
intelligence
that artificial intelligence researchers
have about what it actually
takes to learn to solve a problem that's
fine have you had anka dragon on
yeah okay one of my favorites so much
energy
she's right oh she yeah she's amazing
fantastic and and in particular
she thinks a lot about this kind of i
know that you know that i know kind of
planning
and the last time i spoke with her she
was very articulate about
the ways in which self-driving cars are
not solved
like what's still really really hard but
even her intuition is limited
like we're all like new to this uh so in
some sense the elon musk approach of
being ultra confident and just like
put it out there putting it out there
like some people say it's reckless and
dangerous and so on
but like partly it's like it seems to be
one of the only ways to make progress in
artificial intelligence so
it's uh it's you know these these are
difficult things
you know democracy is messy uh
uh implementation of artificial
intelligence systems in the real world
is
messy so many years ago before
self-driving cars were
an actual thing you could have a
discussion about somebody asked me like
what if
what if the what if we could use that
robotic technology and use it to drive
cars around
like isn't that aren't people going to
be killed and then it's not you know
blah blah i'm like
that's not what's gonna happen i said
with confidence incorrectly obviously
uh what i think is gonna happen is we're
gonna have a lot more
like a very gradual kind of rollout
where people
have these cars in like closed
communities
right
not
it available requires a kind of
co-evolution
that you can't just plop them in and see
what happens
but of course we're basically popping
them in to see what happens so i was
wrong but i do think that would have
been a better plan
so that's but your intuition is funny
just zooming out and looking
at the forces of capitalism and it seems
that capitalism rewards risk takers
and rewards and punishes risk takers
like it
and like try it out
the academic uh approach
to let's try a small thing
and try to understand slowly the
fundamentals of the problem
and let's start with one and do two and
then see that
and then do the three uh you know uh the
the capitalist like startup
entrepreneurial dream is
let's build a thousand and let's right
and 500 of them fail but whatever the
other 500 we've
learned from them but if you're good
enough i mean one thing it's like your
intuition would say like
that's going to be hugely destructive to
everything
but actually it's kind of the the
the forces of capitalism people are
quite it's easy to be critical but if
you actually look at the data
at the way our world has progressed in
terms of the quality of life
it seems like the competent good people
rise to the top
this is coming from me from the soviet
union and
and so on it's like it's interesting
that somebody like elon musk is the way
you uh you push progress in artificial
intelligence like it's forcing way more
to step this
their stuff up uh and weimar is forcing
uh
elon musk uh to step up
it's fascinating i because i i have this
tension in in my
heart and just being upset by
the lack of progress in autonomous
vehicles and within academia
so there's a huge progress in the early
days
of the darpa challenges and then it just
kind of stopped
like at mit but it's true everywhere
else with
with an exception of a few sponsors here
and there
is is like it's not seen as a sexy
problem
uh thomas like the moment artificial
intelligence starts
approaching the problems of the real
world
like academics kind of like ah all right
let let the cup they get really hard in
a different way in a different way and
that's right i think yeah right some of
us are not
excited about that other way but i still
think there's
fundamentals problems to be solved in
those difficult things it's not
it's still publishable i think like we
just need to
it's the same criticism you could have
of all these conferences in europe's
cvpr where application papers
are often as powerful and as important
as like
uh theory paper even like theory just
seems
much more respectable and so on i mean
machine learning community is changing
that a little bit
i mean at least in statements but it's
it's still
not seen as the sexiest of uh pursuits
which is like how do i actually make
this thing work in practice
as opposed to on this toy data set
you